Speaker 1: Hey, we're going to look at a couple
of clips of Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones. You guys remember Alex Jones?
Speaker 3: Pac-Man's a loser, right?
Speaker 1: That guy. Alex Jones has some new
conspiracy theories, including some that he
explained to Steve Bannon, which we'll get to
that are so complicated and so ridiculous that
even his own followers don't get them. And
you know what? I also don't get them because
they don't make any sense. Let's start with the
first one. It's something about Count Dracula.
Speaker 3: The operating system of the Saxe-Coburg
Gotha families, right. Which is the oldest
bloodline of European bloodlines. The
world in which all European bloodlines.
Agree are their progenitors going back
to their founder, Vlad the Impaler.
Count Dracula is the recognized
head of the entire dynasty. They go.
And so this house of the dragon that
flies the dragon banner, the direct
rule. Roll the planet. Just like
Revelation tells us that the dragon.
And it's allied with the other dragon track arms.
And its goal is, yeah, the operating system.
Speaker 1: Chewbacca reportedly also
plays a pretty major role in this one.
It doesn't even sound like Alex Jones understands
what he's talking about here. In this next clip,
he actually he being Alex Jones actually
interviewed Steve Bannon, hot off of his
conviction and he tries to explain one of these
crazy globalist conspiracy theories to Steve
Bannon. Globalist, internationalist, Trotskyite
socialist, unlike Obama, Trudeau, Macron. Okay,
that was actually me. Okay, but here's the
actual Alex Jones explanation to Bannon.
Speaker 3: Hey, no, no. This is good. You need
pain, buddy. Judge, you said and. And Granholm
and all of them. We're doing this in a transition,
but it's not a transition into a better Star Trek
civilization. It's a transition into a new feudal
estate, literally cutting off the energy to make
everybody poor and dumbed down feudalism 2.0. And
so that's that's what the great reset is. That's
what Klaus Schwab is. That's what this professor
of medieval studies Ferrari is. None of those
are his ideas, that's all been some of the Club
of Rome. It's all been said by the Bilderberg
Group. It's all been said by Lemmings to grow.
You know, it's all been said by the population
bomb. It's all been said in eco science, you
know, written in the seventies, but by the
man that later became Obama's, you know, science
czar. And when you read this stuff, if you just
sit back and look at it, you know, this is
the closest thing to Hitler I've ever seen.
Speaker 1: Just sit back, guys.
Speaker 3: This is like Hitler, I point out. This
is like Hitler, Buck Rogers level.
Speaker 1: Right. The other funny thing
is Alex Jones acting like Hitler is bad here,
which is another thing you don't necessarily
always assume Alex Jones will say, okay, so here's
one more. And in this one, this is now back to
Alex Jones show. And he says in this one that
the attack has started, the popular population
has started, there's a second Atlantis happening
and something about nanotechnology. And they're
going to take the food and they're going to wipe
everybody out. Why? It's never clear it's here.
Speaker 3: The second Atlantis.
And you know how Atlantis ended.
And America was founded by Francis
Bacon and others to be the new Atlantis.
And so that's where we are and the decision has
been made. You can see the arguments are there,
especially the public doesn't say no to this.
This is a test to go ahead and wipe out. 90 plus
percent of the population and quite frankly,
of the population doesn't care. It doesn't get
engaged, doesn't get involved. The population does
deserve to die. The children don't. But definitely
the adults and the slobs and the decadent people
that think they're winning in this corrupt system
and think this is all funny. Those people deserve
to die. I'm not going to kill them. We shouldn't
kill them. But I'm simply explaining that
they're projecting their own loathing of
themselves onto us and they want us to die.
Speaker 1: Do you think I mean, so one question
is, do you understand this? But the more
important thing is, do you think it's even
designed for Jones audience to understand or it's
just they're supposed to hear his confidence and
the buzzwords and go, that makes a lot of sense
without even understanding it. Like, arguably,
it's designed not to be understood.
Speaker 3: And I'm simply telling him,
Don't worry, you're not going to have to wait
long. You're going to be in a dystopia and die
too. To go ahead and pretend like you're part of
the power structure or not. But then there's the
real Lucifer variants.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: On top who actually believe Lucifer's
God. They're bringing balance the universe,
and they're very sad about what they have to do.
And this is all part of a greater plan. They're
instruments of this. Incredible. Transformation.
They call it this transcendence that's happening.
So. They've already begun injecting people with
the time delayed kill switches. Yep. It's. They're
already spraying us with nanotech, already putting
in all the food. It's. The attack has begun.
Speaker 1: Yup. And so that kill switch,
basically, you get injected with the kill switch
or you eat it, and then at any point, someone can
basically flip a switch, maybe Klaus Schwab or,
you know, often the people who have the access to
the switch are Jews in these conspiracy theories.
They can just flip the switch and kill
you when you're no longer useful to them.
And as you notice, there's a lot of vague
them and they in all of these hypotheses,
and that is all completely by design.
Again, we don't make fun of mental illness,
we don't stigmatize it. But these are the sorts
of paranoid delusions that you would often look
at medication for. And it is a guy who has built
an audience around it. Extremely scary stuff.